des abus constatés peut être en tout cas
les dossiers des bénéficiaires des apl
aide personnalisée au logement seront
scouts et dans les moindres détails ne
seront éligibles à cette allocation que
les personnes qui en ont réellement
besoin
le gouvernement entend imposer des
règles strictes pour éviter que les
loyers ne soit trop élevé
en effet des propriétés à fixe elle puis
des loyers en fonction du montant des
apl dont bénéficiaient les éventuels
locataires à partir de juillet 2016
plafonds de loyers a été fixée s'il a
dépassé le montant de la paix elle sera
dégressif
autre décision du gouvernement les apl
ne seront plus accorder aux enfants dont
les parents sont assujettis à liez f1
peau de solidarité sur la fortune
cette décision sera appliquée le 1er
octobre 2016 à cette même date également
la caf prendra en compte le patrimoine
du bénéficiaire de la paix elles vont
fixer le montant
nouveauté pour être éligibles à l'apl le
bénéficiaire est tenu de louer un
logement dans le propriétaire a signé
une convention avec l'état d'ébriété eux
aussi peuvent bénéficier des apl s'il
veulent construire acquérir ou améliorer
un logement conditions d'éligibilité
avoir contracté un prêt accession
sociale prêt conventionné ou aux prêts
aidés d'accession à la propriété